yeah thank you guys I have ala with me I
know that it was a shaky day today and
not everything went really right but at
the end you won the game against sanish
gir and I think it was really brilliant
game with so much tactics can you show
us what happened and um some critical
moments there were few sure in this game
yeah um I was very like tilted here so I
just was making explain why because the
previous game the previous game I cannot
lose the end game I don't know how I
lost the game but Sam seven years it was
crazy I was watching it do yeah but yeah
it happens but yeah this game I didn't I
just was making moves to finish it rapid
but um suddenly it got interesting so I
got interested in the game because uh
yeah here again I blundered queen B5 97
I have to go back yeah but yeah
again
um here
yoube he could have gone B5 MH rly
because if I take he just
takes yeah and if you take and take Rook
B8 and he takes on B2 he has very good
position mhm so I don't it didn't make
so much sense R but probably he missed
before so and now I have play and G4
here I think it's very interesting I
think it's about engine will probably
show it's around equal but um it's
always tush position so yeah did you
expect this bishop before or you
calculate only B I only calculated
Bishop B4 in 2 3 seconds and then I saw
Knight A2 at least so I just played G4 I
didn't calculate anything else so he
just to he thought that I'm in really
bad shape so probably I'm blundering
everything I see okay he wanted to
punish you again he was sure I'm in a
very bad shape 92 92 yeah I hear but
it's still I don't know if I'm much
better here because I couldn't find yeah
so no I think I think you were following
this uh the line which is like the main
line so you took on C6 yes Rook A4 he
told me Bishop H7 after but okay it's
very small detail and here I think there
was something yes instead of maybe he
could have taken on d8 somewhere um yes
three okay this is the main line this he
has to push I couldn't find so here I
wanted to ask about this move Rook C8
because let's say your Rook is defending
the Knight and then you also Tred to
take this Pawn let's say or or it was
against Rook C4 was just trying to not
allow Rook c45 I see ah this was the
idea yes so Rook C8 but maybe it's not
the best move because let's say the
computer suggested Rook C1 let's say was
the same or less idea C4 I couldn't and
um here maybe now Rook B8 or yes or
maybe yes so yeah or4 possible but let's
say in the game it was Rook C8 and yeah
F4 Bishop E4 is only move what was your
feeling around here like was very
worried I said I could lose the game
easily also but um I think he could just
go Knight D7 to make draw I think yeah I
think it was also the suggestion of the
computer yeah yeah because I can because
he's playing Knight B6 Knight D7 so if I
take take D5 he just goes Knight B6 mhm
this probably he missed that this is
okay for black yeah you still can take
on C because Rook C1 Rook B1 uhhuh Rook
B1 yes and you don't have the bishop
anymore and you have to take and he
takes the Knight okay but but even here
I think uh also okay probably C1 Knight
D6 Rook
B8 I don't think Knight C4 is correct
yeah Knight C4 I think is fine I think
Knight D3 was a was an issue because I
mean probably he missed your move Knight
C6 huh what do you think I think he
missed the mating that he saw Knight C6
but he missed that this what he said yes
I I think so he didn't tell me so
probably Rook B2 to make sure the Rook
is safe yes so you don't have Knight C6
now yes you then I should go probably
for this and then Rook B7 mhm takes and
takes on C2 yeah I'm better here you're
better yes but still pone up but
probably it's he could hold like this
Knight D6 mhm E5 Knight F5 and he makes
some block it but okay I was not worried
about this because at least I push what
a beautiful mate you found at the end so
how far did calculated I was wondering I
thought first time we made him here Rook
f s yes HG and I think he's draw here
suddenly like I couldn't find Knight C4
what to do here I yes like Bishop B3 you
don't have anymore yes H4 H5 is working
or not I'm not sure I I'm really curious
yeah it doesn't show that much G6 wow
King G King H6 Rook f8 oh my gosh with
some okay it's to too complicated yes I
think oh it's made oh King F3 I missed
King F3 oh so you saw Rook G1 yeah yeah
Rook G1 King F3 I missed okay this
because I have to calculate Knight D2
King F4 yeah okay because it covers no
C1 wow I missing what the Checkmate it's
not so easy to find it with how many
minutes did you have like one minute two
minutes at the moment yes so you play
but this is also V is three is the
easiest way the human way just make sure
that this queen is taken and then you
just give a Checkmate after yeah this is
made so this is made so he resigned um
so um now how do you feel about let's
say today's today and actually yes
that's what you said is very interesting
that you were like tilted in the last
round but things went different and now
what about the blitz part yeah yeah I'm
just I'm happy that I'm down just I
think two points if no I don't know if
anyone catched Ray mhm but if no one
catch at the moment no I think he's
nobody man so it's just two points I'm
happy that it's just two points but it
will be a tough day tomorrow because I
have to catch up two points but still I
catched up these kind of things before
in blit so I like my chan good but I
think y has question for you yes
Anastasia uh please tell Ali Raza that
yesterday we soared he played the game
of the tournament against Wesley so but
it wasn't a victory could he elaborate
on his thoughts about his game with
Wesley so from
yesterday yeah so there was a yaser is
asking you about the game from yesterday
against wesle so what do you think about
this game I yeah this this game if I
would have won the game it would have
been very nice game but it still a nice
game but yeah unfortunately I couldn't
finish the and but yeah yes this queen F
five sacrifice was just brilliant yes he
didn't the most interesting part was he
didn't expect it it was like shocking
for him absolutely but he played it
amazing after like H5 and but okay he
it's really hard to play over the board
for him and he blundered but yeah then
it got messy I should have won but yeah
it was a very cool game yeah I think
your your brother now is doing some
podcast and he's analyzing your games
afterwards did you pay attention he's
he's streaming on Twitch I think he's
kind he's analyzing my games uh
he's always doing this so it's good
people go check him out also yeah yeah
it's nice do you feel some support this
year he's not with you here in St Louis
last year he was here with you yeah yeah
they were all here but now I just came
with my father so but yeah he all he's
very interested in game and always
commentary make commentary for my game
yes that's for sure he's your best
supporter thank you so much ala and all
the best of luck for you tomorrow thank
you thank you Anastasia thank you Ali
Raza indeed that game with Wesley so
that is phenomenal